copé jetons au juste dans le golfe du
saint laurent
cette immense étendue d'eau comprises
entre la gaspésie et terre neuve
la réponse surtout des crustacés
beaucoup de crustacés en 2015 les
pêcheurs ont capturé pas moins de cent
mille tonnes de homards de crabe des
neiges et de crever ce chiffre contraste
avec les captures de poissons de fond
les prises de morue de ses bases des de
flétan ne représente plus qu'une
fraction de tous les débarquements dans
le goal mais quelle espèce possède la
plus grande valeur sur les marchés
à ce chapitre il faut encore une fois se
tourner vers les crustacés la crevette a
rapporté en 2015 94 millions de dollars
aux industriels de la pêche alors que le
crabe des neiges ont rapporté 210
millions
mais le meneur de cette catégorie est le
très recherché omar d'amérique
il a généré plus de 380 millions de
dollars en 2015
un sommet jusque là inégalé mais ce
portrait des pêches est peut-être en
train de changer avec le réchauffement
des eaux dans le golfe depuis quelques
années on pêche - de crevettes et de
crabes des neiges deux espèces qui
préfère nettement les eaux froides
en contrepartie les biologistes observe
que ce réchauffement profite aux
poissons de fond s'est passé flétan ont
considérablement augmenté leur
population les changements climatiques
n'ont pas fini de bouleverser l'économie
dépêche